what most popular sports in Mexico it's
a phenomenon is lucha libre i want to
participate i want to become a luchador
so I'm asking a terrific luchador
Cassandra to help me out Cassandra thank
you so much cool it's important if I'm a
luchador that I have a character
normally when we do this our gears it
represents a part of us so whatever I
wear must represent who I really am or a
part of my true character yeah because
if you lose your back you're done for
life if I'm unmasked then my career is
over well if you're cute you can get a
stick in there Bray from there you say
if you're cute imagine my mask was
pulled off and this face is revealed as
my career over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right and then I fight my opponent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take it your eyes French got my mouth
okay I've defeated many of your best
fighters I think it's time that I toured
Mexico with a partner what do you think
you need a tag-team partner tag-team
partner I've brought one in America he's
known as Andy Richter he's a baby
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
can you tell us about your character
what's what's the whole idea behind what
kind of person would hear the baby yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
baby's on the floor crying and
defenseless and you struck him what did
you do it inside the ring he wandered in
his mama wasn't hooking my mommy drinks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you